you've made mistakes and arguments in
the past with your wife I have yes the
biggest one I found is that if you're
having an argument about an issue stick
to the issue don't start getting
personal and a spiteful that's the one
in it yeah so we were arguing and I just
sort of lost it out and I said I'm sharp
monkey feet yeah I didn't pick this out
of the air my wife has got massive toes
she could pick an apple after years I've
come looking and then the the argument
was over and we resolved it and I was
wrong obviously but there we now we
can't get through the monkey fee as you
never mentioned it before no well yeah
it's not the sort of thing you say is
that
hi baby where's Stella you still remind
you she's with that yeah but we've got a
good enough relationship that I wind her
up will be over the park we were over
there the other day brought my little
boy and early copter straight up in the
top of a tree and I look to our red shoe
out there
and he goes oh you think it's a that's a
good idea have you seen mud and I said
now I see Magic Mike